Hey so it's been a really long time
since I've made a gaming video and I'm
sorry this is me apologizing but as the
Wonder public song goes it's too late to
apologize but to be honest I'm not
really that sorry I still enjoy playing
video games I just don't post about it
as much as I used to either way I was
just playing black ops for this weekend
and the private beta is out I was like
well maybe just bring back some Game
Capture play a couple of games and
poster for you guys I don't really have
a gaming channel anymore but I still
enjoy playing games so let's play some
call of duty black ops war I've been
actually really enjoying this game I
didn't play the first weekend because I
was in Hawaii so I'm sorry I had to miss
it I had a lovely time I have been
really enjoying my gosh I'm gonna who I
really like Nomad because I like his
mesh mine said he does game is already
started okay let's roll I've been
playing the TDM moshpit what I mostly
play I love free-for-all games and
there's me I'm a friend I'm a friend I'm
a friend I'm a friend I'm a friend of a
friend do not hurt me
there's no free-for-all in the beta
there's also no hardcore so I saw a
bunch of people complaining about that
you're big you're a hog I hate you so
much that's the amount of rage this game
brings to my to my soul
I do really well what I'm not having to
talk to anybody except teammates her I
don't like that how are you guys okay
I keep forgetting to heal come here walk
into it walk into it
well you're not okay come on you're a
hot guy you're a pig
Hey oh my god I'm doing terrible I'm
doing absolutely terrible
style UAV come on I just freaking got
all juiced up
well least I got a mesh mind kill oh
you're my friend you're my friend you're
not my friend you're fake you're dead
Oh
wow that's super aggressive
this is there's a lot going on I never
get stuck or streaks because I kill
somebody and then they kill me and then
it's just repeat repeat because I get it
so just yet I get flustered you're my
friend you're my friend
oh and we lost it's a warm-up let's plug
play another one shall we
time to talk to my I'm not talking
anyway but this okay Coco Varma let's
let's collect collect I should stay with
my friends but I have not oh my god no
one there's somebody with me okay good
I've got a friend okay well you we can't
all go in there at once like don't be
stupid
I guess so freaking upset that you
started hitting buttons
we have the advantage
do we do we excellent don't you kill me
let me kill you Pig biscuit batter baby
in a bottle I'm gonna get this I'm
confirming this I'm confirming this at
oh my god somebody else confirmed it I'm
worth this okay who what's today mommy's
got a machete I wanted to make this
instead I'm gonna make that a t-shirt I
didn't remember when I first said I said
I think I said it in a cooking video but
I edited it out because I was like
that's not really moms shouldn't have
machetes
cyber assets dumped oh really oh cool
hey hey hey it's fine just fun confirm
my kill but I got it's like you do all
this work for nothing it's like shut up
brisket something it's not something I'm
angry I'm mad I'm upset about it
okay hear about in the comments you suck
you suck I'd call it shut up that's all
I just wanted to say you shut your mouth
and enjoying myself I'm having a fun
time don't ruin my fun okay don't let go
my fun my cameras probably gonna
overheat the body's gonna overheat so
stop
no I don't want to get lightning I don't
want to get lit man every other game I
play
I want my Katie was like positive and
now I'm just doing really bad and I'm
feeling upset and sad this is why I
don't record games because I don't like
talking I just fell to my death
this is why I don't freakin record guys
I play like a freaking champion and then
I turned the stupid camera on it that I
suck I hate it ruining everything maybe
I can do better
no my team isn't even winning Oh God
trash content
I'm Rican has been destroyed
oh okay okay well that's definitely
something that's happening right now
whatever beat it
yeah hog well some dinner I just want to
confront my freaking kill I don't care I
just needed to get I just needed to
myself okay I actually wasn't paying
attention I was thinking about dinner
I was like hmm she's probably were
postdates now because I'm gonna be
hungry in probably like two and a half
hours so I walk into battle alright
I'm confirming kills boys are you gonna
tell me that I didn't kill a single one
of those people like that's different
shells like things are not working in my
favor right now yeah
maybe maybe that's the problem okay
let's do please don't kill me okay I
like profit yeah okay I'm glad you will
be a hog let's see we could do
well that didn't help
I'm just I'm just shooting into nothing
I'm shooting in a nothing near my friend
well hey nice nice try not here's here
you go get my Segway my Segway is on its
way on its way you killed him
I wanted him that's trash that's
absolute garbage I'm deleting my channel
just another day just another day in the
office that's right look at me I'm in
the office I am actually in my office we
have the advantage
great good work guys I haven't done
anything yet yeah get um razor wire it
is not that it matters you tell me
that's not I do yeah just give you a jab
jab to the face
ready to dig in dig in
well I'm just running around in circles
here waiting for someone once did I
come on now I know you're back there you
hogs
lovely are we just gonna wait here for
them crash requesting strike team deploy
okay I don't want to wait Wow what have
you done
well well great job team I applaud your
effort you're all really great people
and I appreciate you oh that's it I like
that gun oh boy I hope my teammates are
up for carrying me a little bit more
like it's drifting it's freakin drifting
and it's driving me crazy this is just
this controller okay boys and girls put
me in your backpack carry me to victory
Ajax dropped enemy down Oh
[Music]
no Pope I you you crazy I'm out of here
get get it I just wanna I just wanna
swear like at this game everything's
about it just makes me freakin angry and
I yell obscenity is I can't because I'm
back up buddy
mommy's coming out today
well the whole frickin team is here and
ready to kill us what do we do about it
I will just run down here wait till I
can revive myself that's how you don't
go get them
Segway
you're my friend so sorry
holy moly
yeah you just burned all of us all right
guys let's let's pick it up even though
you can't hear me because I'm not on
chat you know friendly
Reuben expired
clear okay great job I appreciate your
gonna be good for this not get him
Oh God I've bought so many things I just
don't even know what to do with it
okay well I'm not freaking ready but I
want my package oh that's my gift it's a
gift to myself I never get care packages
I never get scorestreaks so let me just
have this just let me have it I'm not
even going and I don't care
you can freakin have it cause let's be
real
his mother's a package
you're an idiot I hate you so much I can
get you put you in a gift box and
million I don't know somewhere just
package maybe we had high hopes for my
package okay well let's just get Hogg
even messing with that
I have an itch come on guys let's move
please pick that up thank you
please one I just I'm so bad at driving
this freakin thing like
now whatever time for that Victory's
close reach out them take come by now
oh my god I am like there's so many well
good job team I'm appreciating the
hustle play one more game I hope you
guys enjoyed some of this gameplay I
have been having a really fun time
playing this this weekend and I look
forward to it coming out I'm super
excited to see the slack out it's like
it's the about a royale call a duty
version I know there's gonna be a beta I
think in September so that
in Folsom cute that's gonna be fun no I
was reloading let me let me give me a
freaking second hog
nice
expired expired my body wow wow wow that
was a mistake mistake was made when in
doubt I'm just gonna dive in here and
hide I need to go to yoga or something
cuz I'm raging absolutely raging I don't
like how I feel right now at all are you
gonna tell me I was so I was shooting
right through his brain and nothing
happened
that's the whole team so so let's be
patient okay cool
that sounded violent didn't see it but
if I felt it definitely felt it what is
happening up here no I would like for my
last game to be a win eliminated crush
Wow whole team on that real
gifts of somebody gifts tasks UAV on my
beat
I'm getting this package
yes my precious
annihilates are good to go hasta attack
deploy peeking online Ice Ice Baby yes
at least we came in clutch here for that
last game I wish I had my Apple watch on
right now but I had to take it off
because my arm
I don't even if you tell but like it is
it's got an indentation because I'm
wearing it so much and I weren't super
tight so I can get my heart rate I wish
that I had it on no because my heart
rate during this game it probably would
alert me to go to the hospital okay I
think you so much for watching or who
has enjoyed a little bit of gameplay I
have enjoying this game so much and I
can't wait until it actually comes out
so I will see you guys on the
battlefield or maybe I won't I don't
know that's the end of the video
Meiko dark since I started recording
this
[Music]